I have high hopes for where science will
go under Obama he's talked to talk you
know
so I he certainly scientifically
literate literate in the sense that I
think he understands issues related to
global warming or the energy crisis or
or investments in the National Science
Foundation and NASA I think he has some
sense of that and I and he's been
appointing reliable advisors in those
circles we look at who we appointed for
Secretary of Energy and his science
advisor these are talented smart
accomplished scientist so I have high
expectations for where it can go but we
know the country is in a serious
economic straight right now so the
challenge will be to see what is the
balance between the band-aid you will
put on the problem that you can sort of
stop the hemorrhaging at this moment and
the investments that you then insert
that will return on that investment
later you need the combination of both
without the longer-term investment then
you just putting band-aids on as you go
forward and nothing ever gets
permanently solved it gives the illusion
of a solution but it doesn't actually
change change what the manifestation of
these problems as as time goes on I'd
like to believe that science is becoming
mainstream it should have never been
something that sort of geeky people do
and no one else thinks about whether or
not it will always be what Keke people
do it should as a minimum be what
everybody thinks about because science
is all around us and you know you get
the people who are driving with the GPS
in their car on their cell phone now
illegally on their cell phone say I
don't need science what do I need
science for I got my cell phone in my
GPS I'm fine you know I don't need space
meanwhile GPS is coming from satellites
there's a there's a occasionally you get
people who take the trappings of science
for granted and I have this the secret
plan one day we're going to sneak into
someone's house and take away everything
that's been discovered or enabled by the
space program
for example spun off from the space
program it just leave them be leave them
back there and see what see how they
enjoy life or how much of these
innovations they take for granted
you only notice them when you don't have
access to them anymore and then you
learn fast
yes I do in fact I was three times
appointed by President Bush twice to
serve on a commissions these are sort of
high-level gatherings of people with
hand-picked expertise to bring their
knowledge to bear on a problem that
needs to be solved it faces the nation
the first of those was on the future of
the aerospace industry which was on hard
times back in the early part of this
decade the beginning of the 20th century
21st century and also the future of NASA
these are the two Commission's that I
was appointed to my third appointment
was on the committee that selected the
scientist who the president would award
the Presidential Medal of Science to is
the highest award the nation gives a
scientist so I'm there and I see it and
the the stereotype of Bush being bad for
science if you ask someone what do you
mean by that in essentially every case
they'll cite no more than two maybe
three occasions where bush was bad for
science one was sort of stem cell
research another one was sort of the
environment and it's kind of it really
and okay yeah yeah he wasn't good for
these there was there was a regression
the our advanced in these fields
regressed under Bush but that's not the
entire science portfolio of the nation
the portfolio of the nation includes you
know the physics done under the
Department of Education and the National
Science Foundation and the National
Institute for Health and NASA there's a
whole science portfolio that comes under
the the that comes under the science
advisors office the Office of Science
and Technology Policy OSTP if you look
at that portfolio in fact major monies
were added to that portfolio over the
Bush administration the NIH budget went
up the NASA budget went up although by
less than many people wanted given
what's on its plate the fact the NIH
budget nearly tripled over that time the
National Science Foundation budget went
up meanwhile under Clinton President
Clinton over his eight years the budget
for the for NASA for example dropped by
25 percent an actual spending power
so it would it's not accurate to
characterize the Bush administration is
being anti-science if you measure
support for science by the flow of money